précision concentration les étudiants de
l'université versailles saint quentin
ont quitté leur ordinateur pour des
perles de la céramique et des bijoux
pour cette journée international de la
créativité
le groupe m6 a mis en place la kraft
partie quatre tables accueillent un
public enthousiaste devant le travail
minutieux des créateurs chaque artiste
anime son propre atelier savez que c'est
intéressant de voir à la fois une
une technique qu'on connaît tous parce
qu'on a plus ou moins tous fait ce genre
de petites choses à l'école mais qui
appliquait la a vraiment des bijoux de
créateurs on se dit c'est très joli ses
fins mais derrière il ya quand même
beaucoup d'heures de travail
une manière de découvrir la patience
requise par ces professionnels et de
mettre en avant l'artisanat yvelinois on
voulait faire parler parler de du savoir
faire français de nos créateurs français
qui se donnent vraiment à fond pour des
cons faire des créations made in france
et on voulait bon vous partager avec le
public en général
cette créativité française je pense
qu'on a tous une eau vive et créer nos
propres mains et c'est une possibilité
aussi de donner envie aux jeunes de
découvrir l'artiste caché qu'il pourrait
avoir quelque part un moyen d'allier
plaisir et découverte dans un atelier
qui devrait revenir l'an prochain